Brooklyn's biggest Hospital is flat out
an emergency room that's become a battle
zone but there's a constant stream of
covert 19 casualties
so we're now in the critical care area
of the emergency department everyone
that's in here today is here due to
breathing problems almost uniformly all
from coated we're seeing such a large
increase on a day to day basis on a
number of patients who are presenting in
critical condition requiring really all
the resources that we have to provide in
order to help them dr. Aydin Dikmen says
there are normally 17 beds in this room
at Maimonides Medical Center today there
are 32 patients and the numbers are
rising rapidly every hour we have opened
up new ICUs new intensive care units
we've opened up the new medical units in
order to accommodate for this increased
demand of patients who are coming in so
ill in a city of extremes this pandemic
has been a painful equalizer
this is an intense demanding and
desperate atmosphere in here the
patients keep coming and it's not just
the elderly it's the young too and
they're all struggling
it's a daunting new frontier for medics
even for the most experienced obviously
seeing a large number of critically ill
patients yeah they're being some of the
figure papers I've ever seen in my whole
career not only do they have coronavirus
but they also have their diabetes as out
of control so it's particularly hard and
we're learning how to do it
how to manage it's a brutal learning
curve and an often unforgiving fight for
those with existing health conditions
really the main effect that we're seeing
is its is a significant effect on
impairing the lungs ability to provide
the oxygen that the body needs and then
it spreads it affects the heart it
affects the kidney ultimately
unfortunately often table times taking
the ultimate toll elsewhere in New York
there's a dire lack of personal
protective equipment for frontline
medical staff some are so desperate
they're making their own
Maimonides was well prepared and well
organized but they haven't faced the
apex of this virus yet I think we're in
for a significant period of seeing a lot
of very very ill patients and this is
going to put a strain on the system we
want to make sure that we have enough
supplies including PPE for the staff
including ventilators high flow oxygen
devices at this time we do have
sufficient supplies but that's something
that we're monitoring very very closely
their work has spilled onto the streets
triage tents at the front to tend to the
living refrigerator trucks at the back
to carry the dead
but they're brave doctors and nurses are
working every minute risking their lives
so they can save others who developed
Sky News New York